there are brave men knocking at our door
let's go kill them hey youtubers it's
Charlie and since it's been such a long
time since we've had new game of thrones
season for content I thought I'd do a
nice long preview for each of the
characters in season 4 i'm starting with
Tyrion just because he's my favorite but
you can let me know which characters you
want to talk about first and I those to
the top of my list since I usually post
six or seven videos a week i'll try and
post at least three of these previews
each week I'll try and space them out
every other day just so I have time to
do other stories since this character
preview will deal with some of the
things that may or may not happen in
season 4 there's always potential
spoilers so consider this a warning as
well as a spoiler warning four seasons 1
through 3 and the first couple books
urien is one of my favorite characters
on Game of Thrones as well as a song of
ice and fire I consider it unfair to
compare the characters in the books in
the show too just because there's so
much more happening in the books right
now actually Peter Dinklage is actually
one of the highest paid actors on Game
of Thrones with Lena Headey they
actually get paid about a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in episode I
totally think they deserve it some of
the things that he's been able to do
with the Tyrian character even that
aren't on the page are just amazing
let's talk about some of our favorite
tyrion moments so far from seasons 12
now in no particular order there's the
introduction in that first episode and
the whorehouse remember roz was actually
in that scene he actually had really
blond hair too which i think is really
funny because his hair colors kind of
changed as the show's gone on then
there's the classic Joffrey slap him
sitting in the cells in the Eyrie just
looking down that cliff face that was
actually a really intense episode with
very little action just seeing him sit
there and contemplate his life was just
amazing he almost had no dialogue in
that episode either obviously my
favorite season 2 moment is the Battle
of Blackwater Bay that's basically like
Tyrians hero episode I don't think he's
ever had a higher moment on the show he
even charged the battlefield like a true
knight even though he's half the height
of everyone else he's in three though
it's kind of where he starts to get
crapped on as a character he basically
goes from that really high moment in
season two and just steadily just kind
of rolls down the hill of power Tywin
comes back and it basically deposed him
he almost gets murdered in every single
episode it's crazy one of my favorite
moments in season 3 for Tyrion is his
wedding to Sansa that's really where you
learn a lot about his character he's
ordered to deflower Sansa
he kind of hands over all of his power
to Sansa and says I'm at your mercy this
will proceed exactly how you want it to
proceed I'm not going to force myself on
you or do anything you don't want to do
so obviously it doesn't redeem his
character but it does make him a lot
more sympathetic I also really like that
final scene he has with Tywin where he
basically demands his rights as an air
of castle rock it's really respect that
he wants it's not really about the money
he just wants to be acknowledged as a
person and as a son in the same way that
Jamie is let's jump forward to season
four obviously we're still dealing with
a lot of the events in book three but
honestly because the showrunners have
announced that they're kind of de Partie
even more from the story I think we're
going to see some things from book 4
that's a feast for crows so if those
events from last season aren't really
clear basically Tyrion is kind of like
the new Sansa in King's Landing he has
no power and he's at the mercy of
everyone else and he's under a constant
threat of murder or being thrown in the
black cells let's talk about where we
think he's headed this season and how
his character is going to develop and I
feel like some of the more spoilery
events in the second half of book 3 will
play out and season four I won't talk
about those just because there's such
huge spoilers but basically his
character is in survival mode now since
he's under constant threat of murder
he's basically like a cat that's
constantly not trying to get stepped on
at a party like I said earlier think of
that Blackwater Bay moment as his
highest point and then basically it all
just went to he just started to
slide down that hill and basically
what's the lowest point you can go at in
Game of Thrones or in King's Landing
well physically that's actually the
black cells because they're literally
underground don't you think it's funny
how a lot of the most powerful
characters in King's Landing have
actually had to sit in the black cells
at some point like there was Ned in
season one there was maester pycelle and
season two and maybe Tyrion is going to
end up in there I don't know if that's
going to actually play out but it'll be
interesting to see being a prisoner in
your own home which is basically what
Sansa is right now honestly I think his
character in season four is going to
spend most of his time just trying to
learn to be a survivor what do you do
when you have nothing else to lose I
honestly I think that's what we're going
to see Tyrians character go this season
but let me know what you think what is
Tyrians character going to be doing and
how is it going to develop is he just
going to get darker is it going to get
really awful like how can it get worse
for him so like i said i'll be posting
my
Game of Thrones Season 4 preview on
Wednesday that'll be for Jamie his
character only gets more awesome as the
story goes on but since its departing a
lot from season 4 it'll be interesting
to discuss where we think this is going
to be going if there's other characters
you want to see first to be sure to let
me know and I'll add those to the top of
my list if you really want to help me
out be sure to like and share this video
in the meantime you can click here to
watch that Jamie video remember that
will post on Wednesday so I'll add the
link whenever it posts and you can click
here to watch all my other Game of
Thrones Season 4 videos and you can
learn all about Game of Thrones winning
a Hugo or thanks so much for watching
high five